floods in china droughts in canada and
frost in brazil what do all these things
have in common they're all weather
events being made worse by climate
change and they are having a profound
impact on consumer prices
we clearly see uh inflation now in the
united states it is obvious that we have
a
very very important spike
on inflation i'm
somewhat on the side of those who think
that we may well have an incipient
inflation problem obviously one needs to
watch this very carefully the global
supply chain is not working exactly as
it should be rise and raw materials is
such that we have to act and our
instinct is this will persist for some
time from asset managers to
manufacturers paint makers to policy
makers inflation is a topic at the
forefront of corporate concerns this
year and it's being worsened by climate
change
[Music]
in brazil at the end of july a severe
frost ravaged major arabica coffee areas
and the timing of the cold snap meant
that young plants were most at risk
which could affect production levels for
years joseph rainer a grower in the
south of minas gerais said the freezing
temperatures hurt as many as 120 000
coffee seedlings out of 200 000 planted
less than a year ago and that was borne
out in coffee prices arabica futures
which account for three quarters of the
world's coffee production surged 17
topping two dollars a pound for the
first time since 2014. like uh most
coffee uh suppliers we are uh hedged and
so there's some forward cover here for
the rest of this year and part of next
year but obviously at some point you run
through that hedging position and then
you do face those higher prices
meanwhile dry conditions in canada
coupled with record-breaking heat
triggered hundreds of wildfires with
blazes spanning east across five
provinces and nearly as far north as the
arctic ocean fires have been so
treacherous that thousands of rail cars
carrying grain for export have been
idled for weeks the drought is also
withering crops in canada's bread basket
prairie provinces and in the northern us
forcing farmers to take the rare step of
bailing up their low yielding wheat and
barley stems to sell as livestock feed
prices for the region spring wheat and
the variety used to make flour for
bagels and pizza crusts recently touched
the highest in more than eight years the
biggest
pressure we have as it relates to
inflation because the price
pressure or the need for us to increase
prices comes from the fact that we're
seeing
inflation on our input cost and that is
the most pronounced in in north america
in the u.s these price increases are
ultimately to be transferred to the
consumer inflation in june in the usa
rose to 5.4 percent the highest since
2008. food prices have risen by 2.4
percent in the last 12 months and when
it comes to brands jm smucker the us
food company behind folgers and duncan
coffee said it was planning to increase
prices across varieties of categories in
the last month the overall food
inflation rate is not that much higher
than it normally is there are certain
selected items in the grocery store that
folks may see at least for a period of
time increase costs but we think this is
going to
even out if you will but even if the
economists and politicians say that
price increases won't last what's unique
right now is that extreme weather seems
to be pounding almost every region of
the globe no other industry is more at
the mercy of sun rain and heat than
agriculture and when changes in the
weather can upend a farmer's fortunes
overnight you might notice it with that
morning cup of joe
[Music]